calling all creators influencers people
that [ __ ] with positive sentiment that
have audiences be friends we're about to
really expand the [ __ ] out of the ip
toys collectible cards iphone games
video games mini shorts swag putting
this on my gram so the amazing people on
my team mae she's amazing katie dio
benno boyd you'll be hearing from them
rips they can point to this video in my
instagram feed so there's no confusion
i'm looking for people that want to work
work with us you know some of you from
the bottom of your heart just do it for
the free swag there's got prices i get
it this is your job influencers creators
looking for people that fill out the
form into my gram if they want to be
ambassadors creators partners family to
the v friends intellectual property
explosion looking for original content
brand integration looking for people to
model the swag play the games on their
twitch streams share it integrate it
product placement shout outs let's do
[ __ ] business